hey everyone welcome to metaphysical
milkshake my name is rayne wilson and i
am reza aslan yes you are hey reza aslan
just curious
uh what did you have for breakfast this
morning
let's see this morning i had uh some
delicious huevos rancheros wow neat cool
how did it taste
it's good it's good it's a little spicy
no no no no really i really want to know
how did it taste
i mean it's like it's eggs and it's
beans and it's like salsa like that it
tasted like eggs beans and salt no no no
no no no
did the cheese and tortillas ring
with hundreds of years of proud mexican
culture did the refried beans and chili
pepper
bounce off your taste buds the way an
acapulco sunrise skitters along the
waves of the proud pacific ocean did the
smooth texture of the jalapeno slip
through your tongue
like the silky sands of puerto morelos
i mean
it it was a little overcooked
okay folks you see what i'm dealing with
sounds like someone here
someone in this podcast duo
uh doesn't really understand food
that's not not true not true i
understand really reza really you know
what food is just more than than just
the morsels that fill that we fill our
dumb face pouches with okay it's culture
it's history it's identity it's
geography
it's it's it's a story of immigration of
the movement of multitudes it's all of
everything and nothing at all
okay i i guess i don't understand food
you're right welcome to metaphysical
milkshake the show where we go deep we
get weird and we search for the meaning
of life along the way presented by cast
media and soul pancake
[Music]
so
fortunately for reza's benefit we have
someone with us today who does
understand food okay
steven satterfield is here talking about
how does food inform culture and vice
versa stephen satterfield i know that
guy he attended western culinary
institute in oregon
he became a summer year at the age of 21
like a wine expert
right at that moment when he was legally
allowed to drink wine uh and he's got a
show he has a show on netflix called
high on the hog about like traveling
around the world and understanding sort
of the
cultural connections the deeper meanings
you know he has a there's a great quote
that stephen has
on what he does and why he does what he
does i think my work is a lot about
building empathy because i try and
connect people and ideas through food i
make media about food not just because i
love food but because it's a universal
language that we don't otherwise have
access to there are no other universal
languages except for food that that is
deep profound
so you know this is a guy who is all
about using food to promote social
change he is one of the most respected
and prominent voices uh in american food
media and we thought we would bring him
onto the show to help us answer this
question
are we what we eat
why did your voice go so high why did
your voice go really high
when i asked the question we eat
or we would wait
stephen satterfield thank you so much
for joining us on the milkshake how are
you man where where where are you
calling in from uh thanks for having me
first and foremost i'm calling in from
atlanta ga my
hometown good always in atlanta good
food in atlanta and just
you know a good time to be in atlanta
and um
i always personally feel good to be at
home
you have such a eclectic career um you
know we'll talk about the netflix show
in a minute and
uh some of the work that you do with
regard to food and social justice but
like just give us a sense of how
you came about uh to you know this
this thing that you do like how did you
fall in love with food how did that
begin what's your kind of relationship
with food
yeah for me it goes all the way back to
being a high schooler
um and it was two-pronged one
was in the household so my father
was and is the
primary chef in the family
um so very talented and enthusiastic
home cook
and
also you know i grew up
um
as an elder millennial really at
the height of the onset of the food
network
um in the late 90s when food culture was
shifting really quickly
from something that was
a european fascination or indulgence or
a way of life into something
um that was starting to
be regarded and revered in
u.s culture instead of what it had been
really up until
that point for the last century was um
a vocation to stay out of no vocation at
all actually
and of course we know uh for those
undesirable
jobs filled mostly
um by folks who didn't have the agency
to work outside of kitchens
and so um
i was really fascinated with the media
that was was being made at that time
with the rise of the food network
so i think in some ways that combination
of
understanding food as
the center of the home life
as well as uh an emergent cultural
medium um
you know kind of defined my whole
adult life you know going back to high
school so that's interesting like you
it's not that you thought to yourself
like i want to be a chef or i want to
you know make food it was that you
wanted to explore
uh the sort of the media and
entertainment aspect of
food food preparation food culture and
stuff like that like from the very
beginning it was all
very much geared towards
uh
like a a
media slash entertainment uh enterprise
yeah i mean i wish i could say that i
was thinking that coherently i i can't
take that much credit
um
i think that
well what would actually happen i'll
give you the the linear story
is that um
i moved to oregon as an 18 year old
to go to university of oregon
and i lasted about one semester before i
realized college was not going to be the
right path for me
um but i did love living in the pacific
northwest i love living um in oregon
and so i decided
um to go to culinary school in portland
um and so
basically i was in this hospitality
program
and one of the introductory classes is
um a wine studies class and so
um
you know you you kind of get wait wine
studies
yeah like vino like wine wow um yeah i
know right and um
i was only 19 years old when i started
taking these classes
and i really quickly got into wine i
loved it
and my teacher at the time
was a guy who
was what they call like a garage wine
maker like he was making wine
in the willamette valley part-time you
know for
very little money and loads of passion
um but he's the one who got me hip to
the concept
of of wine as an agricultural product um
which for me
uh at that time
you know i really only understood it
as a marker of class you know and a
language that i that i didn't understand
and wasn't for me to be able to
interpret
so once i started to see it as something
agricultural i really fell deeply in
love with it i became a sommelier at a
very young age by the time i was 21.
i was a sommelier and
really that
overarching perspective of of land and
place and provenance that is so central
to the world of wine
that's really what got me into
uh a perspective on on food and
agriculture that was deeply connected to
human history that was deeply connected
to stories of
migration and identity
and um the fascination for wine really
became a fascination for capturing
um different stories and different
iterations of that particular
relationship wow that's that's
fascinating you know um i'm friends with
uh julia jackson who's the
daughter of the kendall jackson wine
conglomerate
and um she is a very active in climate
change
and the reason she got into the climate
movement and she does a lot of amazing
work
with her organization called grounded
was because
the family saw the writing on the wall
of like hey i don't know how much longer
napa valley is going to be able to grow
the kind of wines we want to grow and
they've literally
been looking for
places to grow wine thinking about
where's wine going to flourish 100 years
from now i mean
iceland seriously scandinavia so to add
to what you're saying about wine i
hadn't really thought of wine in terms
of an agricultural basis but
then you add the climate change to it
and that makes it kind of all the more
agricultural 100
um
agriculture
has long been the canary in the coal
mine for the climate crisis and um
the interesting thing for me you know i
uh i launched a prank magazine in 2017
that was all about food origins
and
ostensibly i was thinking this is a food
anthropology
magazine
that really explores the relationship
and what happened almost instantly in
our
attempt to really
uh pursue this this perspective of
origin
um we
covered indigeneity a lot we we covered
indigenous communities and food cultures
and food ways
and in every single edition we're now on
our ninth one
we got stories from every corner of the
world from communities saying we used to
grow this thing here and it now no
longer grows
and so um
right away
we became um a magazine that reported on
this
relationship between agriculture and
climate
um so much so that as the company has
grown um you know we now have a podcast
actually it's part of a larger
network called climate cuisine um which
specifically explores these uh
relationships both from a historical
perspective and also kind of what it
means on the consumer level today
so it's a big part of our um
kind of world view you know as
far as the climate uh and food and
agriculture relationship is concerned
well i i'm i'm a i'm not a foodie um i
kind of eat whatever's in front of me i
mean i like me too literally
that's scary
and uh
and so i'm kind of new to this but
your way of thinking about food and
connecting the dots between
food and culture and agriculture and
geography and and immigration and
movements of population and sociology is
really fascinating and it was just a
thrill for me to be turned on to your
incredible show on netflix high on the
hog i'm a little late to the party i
know it came out several months ago but
uh
just a fascinating journey through the
origins roots and kind of flourishing of
uh african-american traditional foods
what it means to american culture and
black culture and and everything in
between and world culture
um
just such a beautiful
uh story that first episode in benin um
seeing kind of where okra came from and
you know yams and the and just the story
of the
uh just seeing the roads that the
that the
newly captured
slaves
had would have been forced to walk and
then taking that journey with you back
across to the united states and and
doing it from through the lens of food
just
absolutely um beautiful revelatory so
but to you in your own words what is it
the goal of the show was
we're here to tell the story of food so
what is that story and how does that
work for different cultures this idea of
telling the story of food
yeah thank you um so much you know i
uh really have to say that my role
um in high on the hog though
visibly prominent was part of a really
large and incredible team
who brought this vision into the world
um beginning with the executive
producers
caris jagger and fabian toback and of
course
you know
dr jessica b harris the historian who
gave us
the source material the source text uh
upon which the series is based
so
you know um
as far as i guess the kind of uh
motivation in the making of the show and
trying to show that relationship
you know for us
uh
it was pretty clear
that um
american uh food media
had done
a really lousy job of properly capturing
and articulating the immense and
foundational contributions black folks
have had to our food culture um
going back to how we you know began the
conversation
around who used to do the cooking right
and so
um
while that
perhaps now in hindsight feels like
um what a wonderful opportunity to to
highlight those omissions um you know it
took until
the show came out just this year
for for uh anything like this to have
been done to this point
and so
what
my hope is is that
this work will help others
of all communities of all backgrounds
um really deepen their relationship to
food
um
and
you know make these
broader connections to
our daily lives um as i often say you
know food is the most essential part of
our experience on earth as humans
it's the only thing that we all share in
common as humans
while pooping
which is uh related so i'll grant you
that what how was it but
there's a relationship
um
yeah we'll talk after we'll talk after
um so yeah you know and i think it's
just been radically
utilize and kind of um
you know as as a global people i think
we really lack imagination around you
know how food really can
connect us and um i think
especially in these times as we think
about um
means of making
informing relationships and connections
with people that feel
in solidarity um are really uh potent
and worth pursuing
hey folks
milkshakers this podcast
is sponsored by betterhelp and we are
very grateful for that
do you have something that is
interfering with your happiness or your
well-being or preventing you from
achieving your goals
better help can help as you know i am a
big fan of the therapy i have been doing
it on and off for 20 years
and i have to say it has made my life
much better i love the therapeutic
process it's like life's big questions
but you're posing them to yourself
and then making a commitment to action
and change based on your uh vision for
yourself and better help can help with
this it can assess your needs and match
you with your own licensed professional
therapist visit betterhelp.com milkshake
that's better
h-e-l-p and join the over 2 million
people who have taken charge of their
mental health and well-being with the
help of an experienced professional yeah
in fact so many people have been using
better help that they're now recruiting
additional therapists in all 50 states
so this is the place for you whether you
need therapy or whether you are a
therapist i think both ways it helps
special offer for metaphysical milkshake
listeners get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
milkshake that's betterhelp.com
milkshake
hey milkshakers
and that name
is appropriate because i'm going to be
talking to you about milkshakes well
specifically smoothies today's show is
brought to you by huel h uel my favorite
nutritionally complete
food every hule meal contains the 27
essential vitamins and minerals protein
healthy fats and fiber that i need in a
single meal and right now i've been
starting every day
with either a chocolate or a strawberry
shake
and it's fantastic it's 400 calories
and it gets me through till lunch
i don't feel hungry
and i'm not snacking
you can just work it into your life
when you're busy when you're on the go
you don't want to be overeating and
snacking like i do in my middle age it
keeps you on a routine
it makes me feel happier healthier and
fitter no matter how busy i am you gotta
try it folks
well here's the good news we're
partnering with huel to give all our
listeners a free t-shirt i actually have
this t-shirt it's it's so soft like i
sleep in it it's silky can you use a
really soft and silky shirt
and not just a t-shirt but a free
on-the-go pot
and free shipping with your first order
so all you got to do is go to huel.com
milkshake to take advantage of this
offer
you know supporting our sponsors helps
us make this show for you so show heal
some love
all you got to do is go online and you
can claim your free t-shirt your free
on-the-go pot and get free shipping with
your first order just go to
hewell.com
milkshake that's hewl
h-u-e-l-human fuel
dot com slash
milkshake
yes food can connect us we talk about
that all the time people you know
uh you know from the
days of the potluck to you know or the
potlatch as it said to you know
thanksgiving and you know the ways in
which we can use food to create
community and stuff but food also
divides us
right i mean food
is and this is what i love about your
work is that you acknowledge the fact
that food is
inherently political
right that it's not just a thing that
you eat there's so much more to it the
subject of this podcast episode is are
we what we eat and it and what i find
fascinating
is the intersection of your work when it
comes to things like food and identity
food and cultural appropriation um you
know even like food wars like i i think
to myself all the time about
you know um
the hummus wars are you familiar with
the hummus wars stephen
i am or is it
we brown people are obsessed with you
know who owns hummus right like if
you've been to israel palestine you know
there are there are like battles on the
street that are taking place not over
you know occupation or the stealing of
land or you know whose god is right but
over where hummus came from and who
makes it best you know and uh you want
to piss off you know an arab uh
you know call hummus israeli and they
will lose their minds so
so much about the things that we eat
are whether we're conscious of it or not
uh
you know defining who we are as
individuals and and collective can you
can you talk about sort of the
inherently political nature of food yeah
absolutely
it's really quite simple
and
it's about the land
right
from um
the the 10 000 your story the shorter
version of human history is about
agriculture over the last 10 000 years
and of course before then
um
we were migratory people who were on the
move
looking for our next meal however that
may come
and so
as societies uh globally
uh have started to you know settle
into
permanent fixtures of land as a way of
life
that's really in my view the
the beginning of the central conflict of
food
and this is why we always uh connect the
story of food to stories of migration
and so
you know uh
in more recent history
um
at the the onset
of colonization
um
what really started to happen is a
philosophical
divergence between
the purpose of of the land
and which
a
european ideology
was about exploiting the land
for profit
and tying the land
and food even
to
a
uh
a sea-based
kind of global
strategy for domination
right
and in the americas we'll just talk
about where where i'm from my our corner
of the world
you have uh indigenous populations who
um
basically have been stewarding the land
and in much different relationship to
the land
and
that conflict
uh really the the reason that that
europeans arrive
um in droves in the the 17th 18th 19th
20th century
is to come to the us to find
opportunities
that have to do with
land
right um
including now today with the the the
dream of a single family home
and so what has has happened
um is that the the dominant
uh
cultural
um
force
the in a society um
in societies in which there are
dominant cultural groups whether that be
based on uh
race or ethnicity
these become the groups that get to
write the historical record
right and so it's no coincidence when we
talk about well how did it take until
2021
for a show about the contributions of
black food to come out well because
black folks have not been the authors of
our own history in this country for
reasons that i think are obvious
right and so when you talk about food
what you're really talking about uh and
and why i think there's so much
intensity around it is twofold because
really you're talking about
um again a story of migration or
displacement a migration story
is either
your community your ancestors being
forced off of their land
right for for greater opportunity or
fleeing the land because they were under
threat in other words their way of life
could no longer happen in their homeland
and so this fracture
again oftentimes from marginalized
groups who have to leave
the homeland
the thing that we hold on to in our new
homes that we must piece together
are these cultural memories of the foods
of our home
that's what we get to take with us yeah
see this is fat i love this because
i think we don't think about food as a
shorthand for
identity ethnicity race culture even
religion right but it it so obviously is
the way that you talk about it and then
also you know you were talking about
this idea of like
you know we talk a lot about cultural
appropriation right it's a very big buzz
word right now but we don't talk enough
about food appropriation you know i was
thinking about how i was listening to
somebody talk about like what it means
to be
british you know and they're always like
well it you know it's a love of tea it's
like [ __ ] you stole that tea
you stole them it's a love of tea
and it's a love of curry
yeah exactly
so it's all stuff that you appropriated
is how you define what it means to be a
white british man
uh right now and obviously that i mean
we could talk all day about the way in
which in the united states we have
appropriated the sort of cultural foods
of black folks you know
um and turn it into these you know
kind of hybrid crazy
you know uh nashville hot chicken yeah
there you go yeah yeah yeah oh we're
talking about how like you could go to a
restaurant now and buy like a 90 dollar
red beans and rice dish you know and
like a fancy recipe it's insane
um
but but
it's it's absolutely right that if you
if you understand what food actually
means
uh and how political it is inherently
political it is then the way that we
treat food the way that we treat you
know the food of other cultures um
it says so much about who we are as
individuals and as a and as a culture as
a civilization yeah i mean imagine going
on like a first date or something or or
your significant other coming
to your house and eating your your mom
or your auntie or granny's food
and and not finishing and not really
enjoying i mean think about across
cultures across the world
you know that's a tense situation all of
a sudden right you have hard choices to
make right so so when we think about
just in our own lives you know we may
not be able to make the relationship
about just how intensely protective we
are around our cultural foods
but when it when it comes up in in real
life like we have all been in a
situation where we felt some kind of uh
discomfort or perhaps even rage when our
mom's foods our favorite foods things
that we love and think are delicious
that are part of who we are are kind of
undermined or not appreciated by other
people
is your company or business having a
tough time hiring the people you need i
mean all you got to do is listen to the
news and you know that you know
companies are having a hard time keeping
up with hiring well now there's workable
workable helps all types of companies
there are currently 46
more jobs being posted than before the
pandemic that's crazy 44 fewer
candidates applying to each one people
are getting very picky nowadays you know
so
you need to find the right candidates
and hire them fast and workable can help
workable accelerates every step of your
hiring process from fined to higher
workable helps you cast the widest net
possible by posting your jobs to all the
top job boards that's actually a little
more than 200 with just one click and it
helps you evaluate and hire quickly with
modern tools like video interviews and
e-signatures and also workable will help
you automate repetitive tasks like
scheduling interviews so you can spend
your time on what's important making
hires rain i mean you go through
personal assistance like you know like
it's nothing right like tissue i know
like it's
like butter like wheat for what's the
metaphor
like something
yeah
regardless of what you're looking for
whether you're hiring for your coffee
shop or your engineering team or your
personal assistant
to get your dry cleaning workable is
exactly what you need to hire the right
people fast so start hiring today with a
risk-free 15-day trial if you hire
during the trial which many do it won't
cost you a thing just go to workable.com
to start hiring workable is hiring made
easy
yeah and this i mean it gets into tricky
territory i remember i i don't remember
the chef's name but there was a
chef i was reading about uh who's more
of like an instagram kind of chef
blogger
who like
took a philippine dish and kind of made
it her own she was a white woman and
there was a big uproar of like hey this
is our native
food we have our you know my family's
been making it for generations and it's
hundreds of years old and you can't just
kind of
take this recipe and dress it up
different and call it something else
like that's that's disrespectful
um but yet we live in a country where if
you name american food you know it's
hamburgers and hot dogs which are german
and
uh pizza which is italian and maybe even
tacos that are mexican
so
you know and even fried chicken i mean
asians have been certainly making fried
chicken but it seems to me like the new
wave of like korean fried chicken is
like hey let's take african-american
traditional fried chicken how well it's
done and then bring it 10 000 miles over
the sea and do our version of it so
there's all of this communication about
food going on at the same time so how do
we how do we walk that balance
i could walk to three korean fried
chicken restaurants from my house
wow
um that's like uh
a selling point for the real estate
agent
that there is taco trucks and korean
fried chicken it's true
yeah i mean the way that i think about
it and there's
plenty of of thought on this subject on
the internet so people can
form their own opinions but my feelings
i'm sure it's all very reasonable and
extremely reasonable rational um
um
yeah you know my feeling is that
um
i really the line for me is just around
profit
you know and by that i mean um
even as a blogger if you are um
[Music]
positioning yourself
as uh
an enthusiast right where you're just
kind of following along and cooking hi
this is my my cooking
you know journal diary what have you for
y'all to follow along at home like
i don't know it's it's kind of hard for
me to have a strong
emotional reaction to that if i'm being
real
um
i don't expect folks to have the kind of
cultural education and nuance to really
be able to necessarily discern how they
could be
offensive or kind of appropriating what
i do have a problem with
um is when these same sometimes
enthusiasts
begin to
position themselves as experts and then
in various ways monetize that expertise
and
and
for me you know that includes
sponsorships um instagram influencer
revenue um
because there is a responsibility
that comes with
audience with distribution with scale
we've already seen how
things can kind of go awry without
proper
um
oversight of distribution and so if
you're profiting
whether as this is especially
contentious in restaurants right when
the types of folks who get to open
restaurants and profit from these
recipes and from these cuisines is quite
a distance away
from the folks who have this
cultural memory right these family
recipes
and so that is really where you see the
kind of uh
i think most justifiable anger and kind
of the the greatest tension
in in matters of cultural appropriation
um and then you know as i say for me on
the other end of the spectrum are
people who have basically very small or
no followings or who are kind of
amateurs i i could say
but once you position yourself as an
expert
and you are wielding
recipes that are part of another
culture's story particularly if it is a
marginalized culture whose stories are
already
so hard for others to access for all the
reasons that we just talked about i do
believe there is a responsibility that
comes along with that and so a lot of
the anger and frustration that folks
have expressed on the internet has
really been about uh the most profitable
uh voices on the internet and in many
cases outlets on the internet who
control
uh or who who are able to best monetize
their their content um are the ones who
are appropriating and uh of course the
same for the restaurants as well
so stephen
here's here's my position growing up in
suburban seattle
with uh relatives from uh minnesota and
wisconsin
um
the main dish
at my house
was my father's
world famous tater tot casserole
which was if you want the recipe i'm
going to give it to you right now
one layer of tater tots okay
one layer of ground beef
gently simmered but not completely done
two cans of condensed
steven condensed cream of mushroom soup
and then another layer of tater tots
tots on top and then cheese on top of
the tater tots
um what kind of cheese cheddar cheese
the shredded cheese boy velveeta
probably yeah no no it wasn't we didn't
have american cheese it must have been
cheddar cheese yeah we might have even
been we might have like mixed it up and
gone crazy with some monterey jack you
know
um
but uh
you know
that's your culture right there man
that's your culture rain but uh
how how can i i guess what i mean what's
the what's my question here how do i
connect to my
to my culture and my homeland with that
being the principal dish of my this is
this is
this is a this is a a real issue for for
uh um shall we say white people
right like for me food as a persian i
mean it's all about food like it's
basically how well
it's how we define ourselves like what
is persian culture it's persian food
that's what it is
and in fact you know
as you know that i'm older and i have
kids and stuff and you know my like
whatever teens and 20s i just kind of
like
separated myself from my culture as much
as possible and try to be as white as i
possibly could but now now i have kids
and i want them to be connected to their
culture
in some way um and i only know two ways
of doing it one is to teach them persian
the language so you know they take
persian lessons the only other way is to
feed them persian food like i literally
had to go and teach myself how to cook
persian food
so that i could at the very least well
give your children some cultural
identity
yeah exactly that's exactly right yeah
because they're not going to get it from
their mom their mom
you know like whatever anglo by the way
just sidebar german sidebar the uh
persian food is
criminally under-appreciated
and under-represented persian food
is is so delicious i i love it i love it
gourmet sabzi fessen june
this is come on it's all the kebabs the
kebab stuff is crazy they make rice and
kebabs better than anyone tadik the
burnt rice
um
it's i mean we burn rice on purpose
people
is this
burnt burn is is in quotation marks only
but yeah i mean
but chris
but yeah so for me that's very easy to
connect myself like i really really feel
it kind of you know the stuff that you
talk about about how like food allows
especially like diaspora communities to
really connect to their homeland
especially when they can't go to there i
can't go back to iran right my kids
can't actually go to iran right now so
like
food is the only way that i could
connect it to them but then i think
about rain or i think about my wife
jessica jessica who you know like rain
just kind of a you know wasp
and
uh you know the only connection she has
to any kind of
you know
cultural past is that once a year she
makes uh sausage and sauerkraut for new
year's and like that's her that's
literally the only connection that she
has to our culture and her past it's
really interesting you know i think that
um well there's a couple ways i would i
would answer that
um
this is a deep conversation to me
actually
um
in my opinion
this is an opportunity
for my white brothers and sisters out
there
right of european ancestry
because
what happens as part of the dominant
culture
is that
it it brings you into a place of
complacency
right when things come easily naturally
natively intuitively for you like
it's easy to become complacent
and so
what you're talking about reza when
you're saying i had to learn to cook
because
i'm gonna lose a piece of myself and my
family if i don't learn how to cook and
pass this along
like
that is part of the experience of being
a brown man
[Music]
in a white man's world
and we know that we know that we have to
fight for that terrain we understand
the the searing urgency
of passing down that culinary language
because that is what is needed that's
all we've got right
if we are part of a more complacent
culture
who because of the dominant position
hasn't had to do the same type of
introspection
then it's harder
to have the curiosity to make those
connections in my opinion
because
the history is a two-way street
you know we didn't bring ourselves to
this continent
right
those vessels
were filled
with grains from
africa
had to keep
captured
slaves alive
that's an agricultural story you know
talking about um
tomatoes and pork uh and yes hamburgers
and pancakes in the u.s like that's a
european diaspora story
but europeans
don't see themselves in that story they
see the shame
of those vessels
and that that forced
uh labor
right
but it's harder to see themselves as
actors in that story
and so if i were of say like i don't
know
german ancestry
um in in new york i'd be like hey you
you like the hamburger
you know you like you like pancakes you
like pastries you like donuts
these are my people we're incredible
at baking
you know
like dutch patisserie like
everyone knows about the french but like
dutch patisserie like get into it
you know and so i think there is so much
room
for specific exploration
even if
sometimes the the places where that
exploration leads is like well these
grains sure aren't as exciting as like
all of those spices in south asia
but the presence
i mean in a more modern context 100
years 50 years 20 years and definitely
now of a place like london
where you can get some of the best
indian food yeah in the world you know
centuries later
right like there is a there is a
continuum there
that includes both people of color both
members of diaspora and also a bunch of
europeans right and so i would just
encourage um
you know
my european descendants and my white ken
to like
have more curiosity and and don't be
afraid to see yourselves in those
narratives even though it can be really
scary to do that because when you really
start to look at this historical
um
story of the us and colonization it's
like ooh don't want to be the white
person implicated in that story
therefore my history only begins
you know
50 years ago 100 years ago and so on but
really we are all connected to this uh
500 plus year experiment of colonization
and displacement
that is that is very true but my history
stephen it is a little different my
history did start about
70 years ago
and that was in uh 1953
uh with or ida corporation the creators
of the tater tot
which is a true story i looked it up in
preparation for this i was like these
two mormon brothers who founded orida
they took the scraps from the french fry
machine and just like what do we do with
all this wasted potato let's slam it up
into little
delectable nuggets and they it is such a
delectable negative in all honesty i'm
curious about this right because like
as a white man
um
what do you i do you have like is there
food or are there certain green
ingredients besides tater tots
that like
when you're in the presence of or when
you're eating you think to yourself oh
this is me because like for me it's
obvious like persian food is so obvious
and it's so distinct and like the
ingredients are you know it's like oh
saffron yeah you just go and get saffron
you put saffron into things and then you
make those things persian
but like i i truly am curious about this
for someone like you like i mean
do you have that kind of
sort of deep
psychic connection to food
in the way that you know people of color
do no i i i think stephen hit the nail
on the head i think there's a
part of part of what comes along with
uh privilege is obliviousness you know
and for
us growing up you know i grew up in that
post eisenhower just whitewashed
suburban america and
there wasn't a connection to food you
know they just
there was just food there was swanson tv
dinners and sometimes meatloaf and
sometimes
sometimes fried chicken and mac and
cheese and greens and we just thought of
it as food and so there was a
kind of a a life oblivious
quality to that personally i'm missing
out because i don't have that i don't
have the connection of of of food and
culture and it and it's very tricky on
across all
you know
all
all of my cultural heritage speaking as
the white dude at the table here
although persians are the original
caucasians so
really thank you yes not enough people
thank you very much
uh they're from literally from the
caucuses they're caucasian from the
caucasus
mountains i mean iran literally means
land of the aryans people yes aryan
thank you very much but you know it's um
i guess i don't know mountain bikes
no but i don't know you know i don't
it's it's so different being like you
know what what is white american culture
it's hard to put it's hard to put your
finger on and it's
um
because it has appropriate listen
there's a great grand experiment that
the founding fathers of america
tried in name only to put into practice
which is you know e pluribus unum out of
many one and obviously that did not
work it did not take it was uh
grotesquely unjust
and uh when women or black folk or
indigenous folks or the real americans
couldn't vote or participate in the
government in any way we all know this
whole story but
so
america has a a good concept at its
center that has never been able to put
in correctly into place and justly
into place so
that kind of makes us suburban white
folks a little bit lost
yeah it's so interesting i'm i'm really
i actually haven't had this specific
conversation with a white person before
i um i wonder it's making me wonder
about the
the relationship to land that that i was
speaking on earlier
right because the the part of the
promise of of the founding fathers and
making a country for
white people
um
after the part about owning land was
about getting you off the land as the
laborer
right um and so
i actually think that a lot of
uh white culture was lost in the last
hundred years when white folks left
small farms
in in all in rural parts of of america
in hopes of kind of office jobs
corporate jobs industrial jobs really
you know at the at the turn of the 20th
century
um and i think that was a false promise
and and the folks who ended up owning
large swaths of land were mostly not
working-class white people
and so you know what gets lost uh as as
people of all you know races leave
the land
is that kind of intimacy
with food and identity
um and so i do wonder because of the
the ongoing commodification of the land
uh the extractive relationship to the
land
um in a way has kind of undermined
uh
you know the relationship between
food
and kind of white culture or european
cultural heritage you know i and and i
think that you're you're bringing up a
topic we haven't really covered which is
class and you're exactly right it's like
my ancestors were small family farmers
which barely exist anymore in this kind
of monofil you know mono farming
cultural and economic landscape and
so you lose that connection to the land
you lose your connection to the food
you're not growing the food you're not
eating the food you're not buying the
food from the neighborhoods
so there's that whole economic element
you're bringing up
but here's the magic of
food in my
view like you know kind of coming to the
end of this conversation about
food is inherently political and food is
about class and race and
and you are what you eat in the sense
that you know what so much of your
identity can be
um summarized by the the kinds of food
that you eat or the kind of foods that
you have connections to be they
you know kebabs or tater tots
what's magical
about tater tot kebabs
tater tot kebabs is exactly the point
that we kind of make we can make a
killing although this is what steven's
talking about
that's making a killing on the backs of
all
once we get rid of steven we'll put our
our business plan together but while
steven is here let's be a little bit
more you know pretty toy about this um
classy
i think what's what's amazing about this
conversation the way that we're talking
and thinking about food
is that
in the same way that as we have
discussed food can be used to control
and divide and has been throughout all
history
and it can you know be used to
appropriate culture for profit as we've
discussed but the great thing about food
also is that it is a perfect vehicle for
bringing you know dif peoples of
different cultures together different
classes different
um you know communities together like
when i take white people to a persian
restaurant it's the greatest joy in the
world like especially if it's like
they've never had it before they're just
like oh my god so it's just a mountain
of meat and rice it's like yes that's
exactly what it is and i can eat it with
my hands
yes you can just literally grab it
with your hands and shove it in your
mouth um
and it's beautiful
right if there's there's something
really really beautiful about it so
and you know just kind of bringing this
conversation to a close i i i just i
want you to sort of talk about the magic
of food right um as a means of
not bringing us together in the sort of
cliched way like oh we all come together
and we break bread and it's wonderful
that's not what i mean i mean
you can actually
share a small part of my culture what it
means to be reza aslan
right how i define myself and all the
complexities all those weird markers you
know my religion my race my skin color
my ethnicity my nationality my culture
all of those things that make up who i
am that i that you by definition are
separated from but there's one
thing that i can do
i i you know i can have you listen to my
music or or experience my art but it's
different
i can feed you my food
well that's this is i'm just jumping
super quick and i hear you're obviously
you're you're that was really all i had
to say expert advice on this stephen but
in episode two of high on the hog
there's that wonderful young woman uh in
north carolina who's a farmer and
studies uh traditional uh black foods
the one with the
they're gonna put the freeway through
her yard and um
she had those beautiful photos of the
communal tables that she would invite
people
and and cook for them from what she had
grown right there in the garden patch
and and that really struck something
with me it's like part of it and i'm
gonna go back to being a whitey here is
i have such a
lousy relationship to the act of eating
too eating is something you either get
through in order to watch television or
it's something you do in front of the
television so
um
the idea of a communal table of bringing
people
maybe all the different ethnicities and
backgrounds and sharing food and sharing
recipes and and breaking bread and
communing and maybe it's something we
long for in these coved times maybe
that's that's the antidote to what
you're talking about res yeah i mean i
think that it's probably worth asking
ourselves um
who
benefits from
the
dissolution of
communal tables
right
um so in other words the pepsi
corporation
it's bingo
right
so
when you look at the
industrialization of our food over the
last century
um
it's not just the degradation of the
soil
which we now know all too well
um it's not just the fact that farmers
are getting into contracts that will
keep them working poor
uh forever and ever until they die um
but what is least explored
is the degradation of the social fabric
not just the soil
of people
who
wake up with the sun move through the
seasons live off the land feed their
families
right
that undermines
the largest
industry
in the united states of agriculture
right and so
when you look at uh the potential
and this is why i'm such an advocate for
us all collectively not looking at food
bringing us together in a way that is
hokey or performative or for virality
but really looking at
the ways in which food
has been
ignored and
it as a means of organizing as a means
of community building
as a means of saying
this is who i am
and i'm inviting you to get to know me
on a human level
right an invitation
and so it is one of the only universal
languages that we all share we don't
share
conversations and culture around
breathing or
taking a [ __ ] right we share we share
these relationships
maybe actually it's not my business it's
about the food and so i what i uh would
sort of close with and continue to
um always encourage people to do is in
deepening the relationship with your
food and identity the places that you
will go
on that journey
will really have you asking questions
about who controls the food
and the origins of our food that may
radicalize you in ways that you never
even imagined
all right stephen so we always end our
um
conversations with our guests with
something that we call light the
lightning round so we basically ask you
a question and then you just kind of
give us the first answer that pops into
your mind okay i'm really bad at this
type of thing people are bad at this
most people
hate this part and yet we insist on
doing it we've done
something like 60 episodes and this is
good radio i know yeah yeah
let's try it are you ready here we go
yeah you start right okay
what emotion do you have that you wish
you could better control
hmm
um
uh
laziness
that's
not exactly an emotion but i love the
emotion of laziness i'm really relaxed
look i already gave you all a disclaimer
i don't know okay i am i am as an
emotionally lazy person i completely
completely identify with your uh oh my
god okay next one i'm ready if you could
trade places with anyone in the world
living who would it be
yeah don't drink places with a dead
person yeah no i don't i want to be
alive
um sheesh
honestly right now i think i'm sitting
pretty i'm doing pretty good i'm going
to hold tight i'm being stephen
what is uh something few people know
about you
hmm
few people know
um i'm a big nba fan i almost never talk
about my professional basketball fandom
but i am one
who what's your team the hawks
um i'm a big hawks fan
uh
blazers i'm not really a blazers guy
even though i did live in portland um i
like the hawks
uh
that in itself is a testament to my
fandom actually i feel
um and
i i'm a big lebron james fan i have to
say we um are
the same age i've been watching him play
his whole
uh
adult life and i've always been a fan so
most people don't know that
if you were a food what food would you
be
um i think that i would probably
be uh
rice
oh kind of
bland
white
i see it
i mean first of all um
their rice is quite diverse um so you
know the homogeneity that we're seeing
we need rice that's real food
we we have a ton we have uh the oriza
glaborima from africa
uh of which i am a descendant so i'm
from the rice um just like our our asian
kin are also derivative of rice
also flowers there's a lot of
flexibility with rice that don't
immediately come to mind croquettes
there's a lot going on there
what is one eye-opening experience that
every person should have
everyone should be in a room
where
they are
overwhelmingly
in the minority
name something a lot of people like
but you can't stand
how about friends
the tv show
i just thought for a second i really
honestly just thought you meant friends
like
i love my appeal
that's a thing that sticks with me um
you know from from my childhood i i
never understood it back then
and now my niece who's 13 years old i
caught her watching friends on her
iphone the other day i'm like you're
watching friends i didn't i don't get it
i don't understand the appeal
really i'm
shocked that
you wouldn't see yourself
in uh well i guess that's true gosh
i guess that's true uh describe your
soul in ten words or less
gosh
um
weary
confounded
um
curious
ecstatic
uh
those are that's less than 10 words
that's not bad well done
if you could have coffee with 19 year
old steven satterfield
what would you tell him
just chill
enjoy it you're on the right path
um
you're gonna be nervous
it's gonna seem like it's not gonna work
you're gonna be broke for so many years
holy [ __ ] that's gonna suck
but
you'll be fine and you're on the right
path and i'm proud of you
nice beautiful
and finally
stephen what is your life's big question
can i do everything i want before my
life is over
good answer that's a good one fantastic
steven satterfield thank you so much for
coming on metaphysical milkshake uh
really inspiring conversation
thought provoking
and um
i i've learned a ton and i'm really has
has your show and this conversation has
really gotten me thinking about
food and culture
in a whole different way
everybody go check out high on the hog
netflix season two coming soon when does
season two drop
uh i don't know but we are filming this
year so
soon and your magazine whetstone that
sounds fascinating
yes
uh and podcast network
so we make podcasts from all over the
world print magazines on food origins
from all over the world beautiful
thanks for coming by stephen i
appreciate y'all having me really
enjoyed this chat
i like that stephen satterfield hey
brilliant man brilliant smart guy
insightful very smart guy yeah
but now that he's gone yeah oh can we
yeah can we like go back to this tater
kebab idea
you know now that he's not in the
conversation anymore i feel guilty
talking about it in front of him this is
gonna be good this is gonna be so good
so what kind of meat are we talking
about with the taters
maybe the lamb i think you could the
lamb you could stuff them with anything
right like you take the like like if
they had a tater shell see i was
thinking chunk like a like a persian
kebab like a chunk of lamb and a tater
tot and another chunk and a tater tot oh
you know we sometimes put like peppers
or onions and stuff in between yeah the
fillers put the tater tots between the
meat yeah
so it's your meat and potatoes but
persian style with a little bit of like
scandinavian
uh lutheran northern plains component
and and we can tell everyone that it's
like our attempt to marry our two
cultures we're good friends it's our way
of of bonding but really yeah we could
we could make so much money catching
we're totally on the same page how do we
cash in on this
said every american ever
no shakers you know how we do this uh
when you rate and review us on apple
podcasts and you ask a question one of
your life's big questions in your
comments you get to come on our show and
ask us that question yourself and that's
exactly what we have today we have
shanti from california hi shanti
hi
shanti shanti shanti
i love it
we could ohm you met you get more
shaunty jokes than i get rain jokes i
bet
it's possible it is definitely possible
uh so we're the our assumption is that
your parents were hippies
oh my god you guys are so right yeah
total hippies born and raised in the
middle of nowhere on the big island of
hawaii well that that explains it that
expensive
do you have siblings do they have
similarly hippie names
no i have one sibling and his name is
jason so right
now close enough
jason and shanti
i know trust me when i was like a
teenager i kept telling my parents i'm
like i don't understand why i know i was
first but like i got this and he got
that like i don't get it nobody can
spell i'm gonna tell you what happened
they sold that land they became
republicans
and they were like jason
what about no i mean the brother might
be but they're not
but that was a fair assumption that was
yeah that was fair my name was jason
before i changed it to rain because i
knew to make it in hollywood i had to
have uh jason wilson was just not going
to cut it yeah jason i think there is
already a jason wilson isn't that
probably a dozen yeah
shanti um
what brings you to the show you got a
life's big question you're wrestling
with you're pondering
i do and now that reza kind of brought
up a little bit of my background i think
this question will make even more sense
so i was born and raised a vegetarian
i'm sure you're shocked based on hippie
parents no not right
and it's always been like a weird thing
it's like i get that i'm picky i get
that i'm a vegetarian
and you know people want me you know
it's psychological like and i feel like
it is psychological but i just i don't
know how to change
how to make it different especially at
this age and you know it's it's a
difficult thing and i'm just wondering
what kind of advice you guys have for me
being kind of a weird vegetarian you
wanted you want to change you do you
want to not be a vegetarian but you
can't quite understand
i i would love to like expand my
horizons a little bit but it's like a
psychological thing that i just don't
know how to get over because you know
protein wise it can be very difficult
yeah that's true i bet you eat a lot of
nuts
nuts cheese which is not great for you
especially you know as you know
as the time goes by it's it's not great
that i eat way too much cheese way too
many carbs and i just don't know like at
this point it can i change can i alter
because it is psychological let me ask
you this do you eat fish
no
wow so but you eat cheese but not fish
nothing with a face nothing with a face
i preface this by saying yes that's what
i always say i did preface by i'm a
little weird but yes nothing with the
face and then of course i get the jokes
of like a head of lettuce isn't that a
face i'm like no no no no smack those
people in the head when they say that
i've tried
well look i mean this is this is kind of
a strange question right uh rain because
i mean the fact of the matter is is that
it is better
to be a vegetarian vegetarians eat less
fat less they have less cholesterol they
get more vitamins 10 10 they tend to get
more vitamins you know because they're
eating so many vegetables things like
that more fiber uh
you know and obviously it's better for
the environment i mean we all know what
cow farts are doing
to the world burps absolutely
and
you know we've seen enough food
documentaries to know
you know the evil that is mass
production of
meat
so i guess the the more important
question is
why why do you want to stop being a good
and responsible steward of the planet
and your body
and instead be like the rest of us
well no i mean you're 100 right and like
i i you know i really want to help with
climate change and sustainability i know
that you guys are big on that too but
like you know there's vegan there's
vegetarian and there's you know my
husband happens to be keto and he's so
he's killing the planet what i think how
does that work with the two of you i
don't know you see what i'm saying it's
just like a weird thing a bowl of bacon
for for lunch and you know you're like
eating a celery
yeah that would be okay with it i mean i
think just like you know listen i've
tried to i've tried meat before you know
but but
i'm just wondering like is
yeah you're right do i just stay a
vegetarian and not have any shame on it
you know what i mean even though i feel
like vegetarians are still seen as very
weird like it's cool to be vegan and
it's okay to eat meat but
i live in this like middle ground of
like vegetarians being weird and you
know when you have your doctors going
you're not eating enough protein and
like you're i am trying protein power
but i kind of wonder like do i need
hypnosis to try to like expand my
horizons or do i just feel like you're
fine what do you think rainier i you
know i'm so out of my league on this
question um you know i guess uh
it's uh
this this really if you look at it if
you're if you're taking the 20 000 foot
view you know what is the life's big
question around this it's kind of like
hey is this lifestyle that i'm living
sustainable i'm not really happy with it
um i think you should uh
rethink it and and try some try some
different things and make sure that
you're doing what you're doing
consciously and just not out of any kind
of rote and habit so that's what we uh
attempt to do as human beings is to live
with more and more consciousness in
everything we do and it sounds to me
like you just kind of like eating the
same stuff and it's true
i was a vegetarian
i tried vegan for about nine months it
was it was really hard but really
awesome
um vegetarian is hard because you can
eat bags of corn chips and cheese and
crackers and you can balloon and gain
tons of weight and you could have pasta
right and you could just totally carb
load so
uh but i do think you need to kind of
uh go on a deep dive perhaps maybe some
cooking classes work with a nutritionist
to try and uh live uh as consciously
with your food
uh uh as
as possible um perhaps
perhaps take a vegan cooking class and
and take that extra step toward vegan
for a while and see how that works for
you
that's a really good idea have you ever
gone vegan
i haven't because i you know you're
right the pasta the cheese the chips
those are hard to give up right
yeah i mean you can still eat a lot of
those as a vegan but um
uh it makes it much more difficult but
um
yeah that's that's that's tough but it
it sounds like you have been a
vegetarian out of habit and not out of
consciousness so how do you align your
relationship with food with uh conscious
practice
hmm
that was deep it makes a lot of sense
but it makes a lot of sense because
you're right right i feel like it is
very much psychological it's very
it's very much out of habit and practice
yeah necessarily a good practice
i mean i suppose you are
preparing for the inevitable future
when you know we're all just eating
manufactured food that's basically just
various versions of soy
i mean i made my kids impossible burgers
last night those things are good it's
better than meat
no you have the same delicious
interaction with that with the burger
but then you don't feel like you're
gonna pass out i mean that [ __ ] bleeds
which is weird i don't want to please i
don't want to talk about it yeah that is
weird
i mean it is good my whole family my
whole family eats meat again and i guess
you know
your hippie parents are back to meat
my
my mom eats fish and chicken my brother
eats eats meat like he's it's going so
it's just you wow that's my point like
that's like that's like i guess you know
even more of the deeper dive of like i
always feel like i'm just like this big
weirdo and like all my family eats meat
and they're like well can't you just try
it and even when i do try it i could
have a bite and like you know smell a
barbecue it's great and you know chicken
you know turkey or whatever and then
psychologically i'm like oh my god what
did i just do
and it's psychological
what if she only ate a face
like the face of a cow or something like
that only eat faces confront your
deepest fears i need some therapy for
that one yeah confront your deepest
fears eat a fish face
shanti thanks for coming on the show i
don't know if we were much help and um
actually you guys were i think i think i
think trying something different as well
as you know maybe you know getting some
some some help with the nutritionist and
the therapist i think that's very
helpful
all right good
all right thanks for calling in thank
you guys so much
bye bye and uh milkshakers as you know
we would love to have you on our show
please write us on the old social media
leave us a positive review on apple
podcasts and post your life's big
question we'll track you down and bring
you on the show and have a scintillating
discussion with you we love to hear from
our listeners metaphysical milkshake is
executive produced by rayne wilson reza
aslan and colin thompson it is produced
by safa samazadeh yazd harris lane mick
dimaria hashem self and dj lubell
cast media is the production and
distribution partner original music by
jeff tang
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
although persians are the original
caucasians so
really thank you
thank you enough people thank you very
much
uh they're from literally from the
caucuses they're caucasian from the
caucasus
mountains i mean iran literally means
land of the aryans people yes aryan
thank you very much
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you